why didn't so many people go after  ancient tape because he's literally the  Auntie woke like he's the Auntie of  everything that they're promoting so I  don't even think it has anything to do  with his so-called misogynistic views I  don't really think they're misogynistic  I think it has everything to do with the  fact that he's pulling people out of the  Matrix he's waking people up he's saying  nobody's coming to save you forget that  nine to five you need to save yourself  you don't need antidepressants let me  teach you how to fight depression by  yourself what does that do because the  pharmaceutical companies out of work  right and so it's because he's a  literally empowering men to save  themselves and I think that men are the  Forefront of society so if you have  strong men then Society can flourish in  every different way